قبل انتصاف الليل بقليل عشرات الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه تدخل مدينه رام الله
باتجاه بلدتها القديمه
الهدف هدم منزل يعود لعائله الفروخ بتهمه
ان ابنها اسلام خطط ونفذ عمليتين في القدس
العام الماضي قتل خلالهما مستوطنا
البيت هذا بنى
في سنه 1990 تقريبا
تعبنا احنا والوالد الله يرحم الوالد تعب
فيه لمن بناه واحنا تعبنا فيه
سياسه العقاب الجماعي هاي انا بنصح
الاحتلال ما يستمر فيها لانه من سبعين سنه
وهو يمارس هاي السياسه لا تسمن ولا تغني
من جوع
الجيش الاسرائيلي نشر صورا لعمليه تلغيم
المنزل ثم تفجيره
تنفيذا لقرار وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الذي يجري هو اعاده احتلال كامل للضفه
الغربيه سواء كان ذلك منطقه الف منطقه باء
منطقه جيم واضح تماما ان هذه الحكومه في
اسرائيل تعيد احتلال كامل مفاصل الضفه
الغربيه الجيش الاسرائيلي اعتقل عددا من
الفلسطينيين خلال مواجهات عنيفه بين الجيش
والفلسطينيين الذين حاولوا منع عمليه
الهدم هذا الركام يضاف الى ركام قرابه
الستين منزلا هدمها الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ
بدايه العام في اجراء يراه الفلسطينيون
عقابا جماعيا يطال ابسط حقوق الانسان
من منزل الفروخ في رام الله التحتا خالد
القاسم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات